hello everyone this next game is a very
famous chess miniature one of the most
famous I would say it was played by one
of the greatest Slovenian grandmasters
album planning and the planning's was a
real strong guy he two years prior to
this game in 1973 he he shared first
place with Tigran Petrosian in Amsterdam
Savion challenge ahead of Boris Spassky
and this game he's playing against the
Armenian Grandmaster Rafael de gallo and
it's a really nice game it really shows
how simple the easy decision to grab a
pawn can really make the game take a
wrong turn
so let's hit again Vergara and his wife
endpoint is black B for Knight to f6 c4
c5 the Benoni but we're going to employ
Knight 2 X 3 so we have seek after
Sunday 4 nights after 74th and e6 Knight
to c3 Bishop to b4 an idea to b5 black
castles a3 Bishop captures on c3 to
Knight captures on c3 and now d5 and the
white plays the Bishop to g5 adding
pressure to the center planning plays h6
we have Bishop captures on f6 Queen
captures on f6 and now tickets for 75
geek after Sun d5 and this is kind of
the critical position of the game well
okay white white has a chance to win a
pawn here but his King is still an e1
and he should really consider not not
becoming materialistic here and the
computer could probably get away with
grabbing this bone but for a human this
is a pretty hard to play but
nevertheless both of them are really
sharp tactical players and they enjoy
well sharp lines so he plays Queen
captures on d4 and the police fire up
the d8 okay we have twin to f3 offering
the exchange of Queens and pointing this
place with Queen to b6 now attacking
this B to bond and
Vogon defends correctly rook rook rook
to d1 and now this one cannot be taken
as this rook is attacked mv8
so play nice captures the rook rook
after sandy one
and nice casters on d1 not protecting
that b2 bond we have a knight to c6
nicely developing 23 again offering the
threat of Queens but one Sims plays nice
to d4
we have Queens e e8 check King 287 and
okay it seems like black has some
troubles here he can't really develop
the bishop and well if you can develop
the bishop he can develop the rook as
well so I think we played III to kick
the night and prepare to develop himself
but when he plays Knight to see to check
we have Kings to d2 and this is a very
nice move by means as now he showed that
the bishop can indeed be developed
he plays Bishop to f5 and this is a very
nice move it defends the night and c2 so
the King cannot capture it and well he's
really not leaving white wood with any
choice if the Queen moves and doesn't
capture the rook then simply wrote to
the a check and it will be over quickly
so Queen captures on a is pretty much
forced so a nice work sacrifice and he
finds plays a queen to d6 and it's
really hard for whites to choose his
next move and if if white were to play
something like King to e2 then it's it's
actually a force mating 9 news after
Queen to b3 check King to f3 we have
Queen after sandy 1 check Bishop to e2
nice to d4 check King to f4 Knight
captures any two good checks came back
to f3 Knight to d4 check again
it's a double check from the knight and
the Queen King to f4 and now the Queen
pushes the King further Queen to g4
check King to e5 Quinta efore check King
to d6
Queen to c6 check King t7 Queen to d7
check King to f8 and not simply nice to
e6 is checkmate
so obviously began and saw this and
after Queen to d6 he plays King to c1
but now planning's has also a very nice
idea and knights to a-1 and the threat
is nice to be three checkmate and if
white were to play this correctly he
should have played something like Bishop
before maybe and although black is
better here he could have prolonged the
games some mornings but Lagrangian plays
Queen Catherine b7 to protect check mate
with the Queen and of course blacks next
move is completely obviously plays Queen
to c6 check and the game is over if if
the Queen captures the Queen then well
it's pretty straightforward
let the b3 is checkmate as planned and
well on the other move then to capture
the Queen would be to block this check
with the knight or with the bishop and
then well and then was hoping so after
this very nice Queen c7 check idea
rapava Ghanian resigned and well thus
this great miniature was was born I do
hope you enjoyed this game it's a very
nice very nice final position with these
two queens staring at each other
one square with no squares apart and
yeah I do hope you enjoyed it as usual
you can check two of my previous videos
here and thank you for watching and I'll
see you soon